das wollen wir sehen mit erhard scherfer
nichts anderes als gerüchteküche bleibt
er hat bis dann der aktuelle stand aus
ihrer sicht naja ich glaube dass mit der
gerüchteküche können wir jetzt ein
bisschen beiseite räumen oder
meinetwegen auch
zur seite treten lassen denn es scheint
relativ sicher zu sein dass es heute
eine pressekonferenz geben wird der
koalitionäre und das ist gar nicht mehr
auf gerüchte basis sondern karl
lauterbach selber hat das gesagt vor
wenigen minuten im ard morgenmagazin
dass im laufe des tages mit
informationen zu diesem
koalitionsvertrag zu rechnen sei das hat
sich gestern tatsächlich ja auch
angedeutet weil der fahrplan da nochmal
bekannt wurde gestern beziehungsweise ja
bis heute gemacht haben die koalitionäre
noch einmal verhandelt auch heute im
laufe des vormittags waren sie da noch
mal zusammenkommen und noch einmal
abschließend über das schauen was
bislang besprochen beredet und
aufgeschrieben worden ist und dann war
deutete sich an was ja ohnehin diese
woche passieren sollte deutete sich an
dass möglicherweise auch heute im laufe
des tages neben diese pressekonferenz
geben kann und so scheint es jetzt auch
zu kommen geber noch mal bevor wir in
die details gehen wo vielleicht die
knackpunkte gelöst wurden auf den
fahrplan ein wie sie es denn dann aus
noch vor weihnachten möglicherweise dann
einen neuen kanzler stolz oder also wenn
die einigkeit heute tatsächlich da ist
und sagen wir mal heikki pressekonferenz
heute selbst sind sie morgen käme wenn
ich relativ sicher dass wir an
weihnachten eben diesen neuen
bundeskanzler haben es ist ja vorgesehen
dass die spd am vierten dezember einen
sonderparteitag macht einen kleinen die
fdp dann am fünften und bis zu diesem
fünften dezember sollte auch
abgeschlossen sein eine
mitgliederabstimmung bei den grünen
findet das ganze jahr online statt nicht
bei einem parteitag sondern wir können
die mitglieder sich sowohl zu dem
koalitionsvertrag als auch zu dem
personaltableau dass die grünen-spitze
dann aufgestellt und bekannt gemacht
haben sollte abstimmen und diese
ergebnisse das gefühl das ganze
verfahren sind ungefähr zehn tage
veranschlagt dieses ergebnis sollte dann
auch am fünften spätestens am 6 dezember
vorliegen am 6 dezember könnte dann
beispielsweise der koalitionsvertrag
unterzeichnet werden auch da gibt es ja
feste termine immer größerem aufwand das
ganze stattgefunden hat wird
wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so klappen
aufgrund der pandemie
dann kann tatsächlich am 7 8 oder
spätestens am 9 ein neuer bundeskanzler
gewählt werden sprechen oder nehmen wir
uns diesen möglichen koalitionsvertrag
inhaltlich an müssen denn die
knackpunkte wo es jetzt einen durchbruch
gegeben zu haben scheint in deutschland
ja inzwischen einigermaßen alles gelöst
zu sein damit möglicherweise heute dann
nur noch an ein paar feinheiten über
feinheiten reden man wird mit sicherlich
mit sicherheit heute auch noch mal über
das personaltableau reden wenn man heute
in einer nacht das geschafft haben
sollte die ressortverteilung
beziehungsweise auch die
ressortzuständigkeiten festzulegen da
kann man gar soll war ja immer wieder im
gespräch dass es unterschiedliche
zuschnitte geben soll ein eigenständiges
bauministerium etwa
im gespräch und dann ist auch die frage
was macht man zum thema klimaschutz
nimmt man das umweltministerium welche
befugnisse welche kompetenzen kommen
danach dazu möglicherweise befugnisse
die bislang im wirtschaftsministerium
liegen wenn es etwa um industrie und
energie geht solche dinge all das muss
sie abschließend beraten sein dank wäre
der nächste schritt wäre bekommt welches
ministerium und dann der letzte
abschließen dann von welchen personen
werden diese ministerien dann geleitet
in zukunft und das ist der entscheidende
und wichtige schritt und der sollte dann
spätestens heute vormittag abgeschlossen
sein wenn man am nachmittag eine
pressekonferenz geben will von dem was
ich hier von außen höre und sehe scheint
er die energiewende ein schwerpunkt auch
ein durchbruch gewesen zu sein wie wird
sich das entwickeln was wird sich auch
ändern für uns menschen draußen das ist
schwer zu sagen im moment da muss man
gucken wie die
beschlüsse tatsächlich aussehen und wir
sehen ja auch ein koalitionsvertrag ist
das eine die wirklichkeit ist das andere
dass sich diese zukünftigen koalitionäre
im moment hauptsächlich oder zumindest
was die schlagzeilen und die medien
öffentlichkeit und angeht hauptsächlich
mit pandemie fragen beschäftigen müssen
während im hintergrund natürlich die
anderen felder auch bearbeitet werden
zeigt schon dass das da die die
wirklichkeit also einen
koalitionsvertrag auch schon mal schnell
überholen kann es ist gestern bekannt
geworden im zusammenhang mit dem
koalitionsvertrag dass der kohleausstieg
vorgezogen werden soll idealerweise
auf das jahr 2030 heißt es unter der
voraussetzung dass die
versorgungssicherheit gewährleistet ist
auf der einen seite und dass auch die
soziale härten für beschäftigte
vermieden werden können dann hat das
außerdem beschlüsse gegeben über die
zukünftige beheizung von wohnungen also
dass beispielsweise gasheizung ist nicht
mehr geben soll und nach wie vor offen
aber beziehungsweise nicht unverändert
im vergleich zum sondierungs papier ist
die frage dass der kraftfahrzeuge mit
verbrennungsmotor da soll sich wohl erst
mal nichts ändern also das sind so die
punkte die im moment bekannt sind wir
müssen gucken was diese pressekonferenz
tatsächlich hergibt was in diesem
koalitionsvertrag dann tatsächlich steht
und dann wird man natürlich auch sehen
was sich in zukunft aendern muss
irgendwann klimaschutzziele
beispielsweise erreicht werden sollen
aber das ist ja nur ein wichtiger punkt
den sich diese neue koalition als
aufgabe gesetzt hat man will ja
transformation auch in der gesellschaft
in der wirtschaft und vielen anderen
bereichen auch was hört dann über den
stil dieser verhandlung es trinkt ja
wirklich wenig nach außen
ja das ist wirklich faszinierend wie
haben sie eben in dem ein spieler gerade
auch gesehen die grünen glaube ich die
grünen-spitze die das willy brandt haus
verlassen hat heute macht dass sie
gesagt haben sie sind aber hartnäckig
will sagen aber trotzdem nichts das ist
wirklich beeindruckend gewesen dass über
die ganze die ganze zeit wenig nach
draußen gedrungen ist über den
jeweiligen verhandlungsstand es hat zwar
unzufriedenheit immer mal wieder gegeben
insbesondere bei den grünen die nun aber
jetzt offenbar sehr zufrieden sind mit
den ergebnissen bei spaß den klimaschutz
angeht ansonsten hat man sehr diskret
verhandelt sehr ruhig und das ist
natürlich der möglicherweise dann oder
hat möglicherweise dann auch dazu
geführt dass diese verhandlung doch
relativ schnell über die bühne gegangen
sind das sind ja jetzt seit dem ende der
sanierung
beginnt der koalition
koalitionsverhandlungen und bis heute
gerade mal vier fünf wochen ins land
gegangen das ist nicht wirklich viel
wenn man sich anguckt wie
unterschiedlich die parteiprogramme
dieser drei in vielen punkten doch sind
er hat besten lagen für diese
einschätzung wird ein spannender tag
würde ich aus ihren einordnung heraus
und ich sage mal höflicher
hartnäckigkeit hilft das als motto für
den tag dankeschön erhält